the explosion was just after 1 30 as
friday prayers were starting at a shiite
mosque in the northern afghan city of
kunduz
a suicide bomber blew himself up and the
dead are still being counted
it was around 1 40 in the afternoon all
the muslims had gathered in the mosque
for friday prayers and then i heard the
explosion i was nearby and what i saw
was just like the end of the world
islamic state has carried out a number
of attacks across the country since the
taliban retook control and in particular
they have targeted mosques
people of afghanistan were already
you know suffering catastrophe by
poverty by oppression now facing a new
wave of um
exclusions and
losing their loved ones
islamic state is attracting fighters to
afghanistan from elsewhere in the world
they are growing larger and bolder it is
a real challenge to the new taliban
government if they can't keep the people
safe they will quickly lose support
[Music]
this would be the first time islamic
state has launched an attack in the
north of the country their stronghold is
in eastern afghanistan the power
struggle following the nato withdrawal
is still playing out and afghans are
again caught in the middle
alastair bunker sky news